very briefly I do want to have as an
interlude here it was a very weird day
for Elon Musk on Election Day musk
shared a Nazi meme to Twitter and then
told his followers to vote for
Republicans not a particularly normal
day Ellie Quinlan huffdaleing writing a
good summary of this in The Daily Beast
um Elon Musk posting a how times have
changed meme to Twitter this got 43 000
retweets and 180 000 likes in a couple
hours it's a Nazi meme it uses a photo
of a German soldier with a cage of
carrier pigeons during the Nazi invasion
of France it had about 14 000 retweets
in the three hours after it was posted
um and so
that was sort of a weird thing to do and
then Elon Musk suggested on Twitter that
everybody vote Republican Elon Musk
saying to independent-minded voters
shared power curbs the worst excesses of
both parties therefore I recommend
voting for a republican Congress given
that the presidency is democratic this
is very very stupid and I will tell you
why
even if in the abstract you believe that
absolute power
corrupts people absolutely
you have to consider what we're talking
about even when controlling the White
House House and Senate Republicans still
have extraordinarily ex when Democrats
control those three
Republicans have shown they have
extraordinary power to obstruct the
things Joe Biden wants to do uh most
things require 60 votes in the Senate
Democrats have not had a super majority
and as a result everything has been a
fight for Democrats the idea that oh
Democrats have had basically carte
blanche to do whatever they want is
untrue so the framing of this idea is
untrue furthermore
divided power isn't good
just for its own sake if the people that
would hold some of that power
have no business doing so people like
Herschel Walker
people like Mehmet Oz Governors like
Doug mastriano or Kerry Lake and so this
is the prototypical what I call
enlightened Centrist type post Elon Musk
likes to say I'm an independent I've
mostly voted for Democrats up until this
year now I suggest voting Republicans
because we want you know they're both
the same and we've got to divide power
and
this is the prototypical prototypical
enlightened Centrist type argument it is
nonsense and fortunately there was no
red wave